hello grammarians we're talking about
irregular verbs that is to say that
verbs that aren't formed like regular
verbs and to give you a taste of what
regular verbs look like just as a
refresher let's take the word walk let's
put it in the present tense and now
normally under normal circumstances we'd
want to just add an ed to it in order to
form the simple past tense so we go from
walk to walked we add this ed ending
and it turns out that there are a lot of
irregular verbs that also behave the
same way when we make the past tense we
have this sound it's just that they're
not represented that way in the spelling
i'll give you an example the present
tense form of the word to sleep is sleep
and when we put it in past tense it is
not sleeped
but slept the
part of slept
does the same work as the ed ending
for the regular plural
so sleep becomes slept is the same as
walk becomes walked
likewise keep becomes kept build becomes
built
spend becomes spent leave becomes left
leap becomes lept
and lose becomes lost so although these
verbs are all irregular verbs within
their irregularity at least in this case
there is some common distinctions
they're all still trying to make the
same sound as walked
it just displays differently
so it's not sleeped but slept not keeped
but kept not builded but built not
spended but spent not leaved but left
not leaping
but left
not losing but lost
at least as it applies to modern
standard english
and that my friends is the funky e.d
you can learn anything
david out